[Music]
greatest basketball player of all time
had the NBA's top salary only twice in
15 seasons but a historic Nike deal an
investment in a floundering NBA
franchise made him the world's richest
athlete with a 2.1 billion dollar
fortune Michael Jordan earned 90 million
dollars during 13 seasons with the Bulls
and 2 years with the Wizards plus
another four million dollars from the
Bulls when he sat out to play minor
league baseball
it wasn't until his 12th season with
four NBA titles and MVP awards that
Jordan was finally awarded the league's
top salary he got 33 point 1 million
dollars the next year before retiring at
the end of the 97-98 season and while
the NBA made Jordan famous his sponsors
made a rich he earned 1.7 billion
dollars in endorsements off the court
and still reps top brands in retirement
Nike was by far his biggest money earner
Jordans initial five-year deal signed in
1984 was worth $500,000 annually plus
royalties Nike built the jordan brand
into a massive standalone business nike
share of the u.s. basketball performance
shoe market which includes the Jordan
Brand was 86 percent in 2019 Jordans
take from that last year a hundred and
thirty million dollars in 2006 he fought
a minority stake in the Charlotte
Bobcats which have since been renamed
the Hornets he took majority control of
the team in 2010 in a deal valued at 175
million dollars he eventually raised his
stake to 90 percent Jordan cashed in
some of his Hornets equity in September
when he agreed to sell roughly 20
percent of the team and a 1.5 billion
dollar valuation while the Hornets are
by far Jordan's biggest investment he's
invested in sport radar gigster music
and axiomatic the parent company of
esports quad team liquid recently valued
at 320 million dollars and on top of
that his stake in tequila brands and
Koro his investment in the MLB's Miami
Marlins his partnership in cornerstone
Restaurant Group and lest we forget his
ownership of a car dealer in North
Carolina Jordans diversification has
secured him quite the fortune most
billionaires have lost money between
2019 to 2020 but not MJ in the last 12
months his net worths shot up 300
million dollars thanks to a higher value
for the Hornets and 145 million dollars
in earnings largely from Nike